Everyone has a tell.
It's after six. What am I, a farmer?
That is the cutest thing I've ever seen!
Isn't that adorable?
You have to fire ten percent of your staff.
I like you.
You have the boldness of a much younger woman.
Now let me hear you say the seven most important words in the American judicial system.
My client has no memory of that.
Pete, did you know that men with full heads of hair, on average,...
...earn 17 percent more than their bald counterparts?
I did not know that.
You see, in poker as in business,...
...the key to success is to determine your opponent's strength...
...and more importantly, his weaknesses.
Everyone has a tell.
Like when Frank is bluffing, he asks a series of inane questions to hide his nervousness.
Oh, really? Is that what you think?
Is that what I do?
I'm sorry for what's about to happen right now. Just know that I don't mean it.
Don't mean what?
What group home did you escape from that you would dare talk to me like some plumber's wife...
...in front of Ron Gordon and Bob Overmyer?
Oh, snap!
Why are you wearing a tux?
It's after six. What am I, a farmer?
So we can either do this the easy way or the hard way.
What's the hard way?
You do a live Christmas Eve's special from Kabul every year until the war on terror is won.
You're always gonna be my son.
Tracy, just because I stopped loving your dad doesn't mean we've stopped loving you.
Stop putting words in my mouth, woman!
Oh, yeah? Poppy, be quiet! People are sleeping!
That is terrific. I really enjoyed that.